des statues d'or et d'argent des pierres
précieuses du plus grand raffinement ces
pièces proviennent toutes du trésor de
naples un trésor inestimable à l'origine
peu banal pour en comprendre l'histoire
il faut remonter au 16e siècle
les napolitains pour se prémunir de la
peste des désastres provoqués par les
guerres ou encore de l'éruption du
vésuve leur terrible volcan décide de se
placer sous la protection de san gennaro
un saint ou pouvoirs miraculeux mais ils
choisissent pour cela il faut il te
doutes vont imaginer faire un contrat
avec le ca on est en 1527 tank san
gennaro je me dis est mort en 305 donc
bien avant et symboliquement mais très
officiellement ce contrat va être passée
devant notaire donc les napolitains d'un
côté san gennaro de l'autre ils
s'engagent mutuellement à protéger la
ville donc san gennaro protège la ville
et parallèlement les aider et la
politesse s'engage à construire une
chapelle pour garder ce qui devient déjà
un petit peu le trésor de san gennaro
problème ce trésor qui se développe au
fil des ans n'appartient juridiquement
ni à la ville de naples ni à l'église
impossible de vendre la moindre pièce i
ly dont continuent d'affluer aujourd'hui
encore il se dit qu'il serait le plus
important au monde devant le trésor de
la couronne d'angleterre et même celui
de la russie de nombreux souverains se
faisait un devoir d'offrir des oeuvres
toujours plus magnifique pour s'attirer
les bonnes grâces du saint protecteur et
de la politique comme cette ostensoir
cadeau de napoléon d'ordinaire plus
enclins à prendre qu'à offrir
et puis il ya aussi ces sculptures
impressionnante notamment de par leur
taille
on a ici devant nous une sculpture qui
fait un mètre 80 tout en argent et
argent doré qui est exceptionnel par sa
dimension par sa qualité par ses
matériaux et aussi par le sculpteur qui
est derrière
mille oeuvres constitue le trésor de
naples elle ne quitte que très rarement
la chapelle napolitaine dans laquelle
elles sont conservées présenter une
quinzaine d'entre elles pour cette
exposition constitue un petit exploit
pour cette commune de 7000 habitants du
sud de l'indre et loire
un bon moyen pour parfaire une image
déjà très teintée d'italie l'os est
quand même peu d'italie avec la
renaissance donc c'est puis on a des
grands personnages qui ont marqué un peu
notre notre histoire et surtout aussi
bien on allait caravage de philippe de
béthune on a fort ça peut-être à
saint-ours et l'italie les petites rues
de los font penser à l'italie
l'exposition trésors de naples sera
visible à la chancellerie de loches
pendant tout l'été jusqu'au 1er octobre
nous